y en directo Vamos hasta Santiago con
nuestra corresponsal en Chile Patricia
Luna con quien discutiremos sobre el
viaje del presidente Gabriel borich a la
región de la auracanía Su primera visita
como mandatario a un territorio que ha
sido el epicentro de conflictos entre el
estado chileno y el pueblo mapuche
Patricia muy buenas noches cuéntenos
cómo fue recibido boric en la araucanía
primera y muy esperada visita del
presidente a la alcaldía como señalabas
aunque no esperaba por todos al
parecerra por los diversos cortes de
rutas que se han registrado en
carreteras regionales y también por
ataques incendiarios especialmente
simbólicos recordemos que es una zona
donde se producen ataques e incendiarios
de forma constante casi diaria pero en
este caso se quemaron tanto una escuela
rural como una iglesia católica en la
escuela se dejó un Lienzo contra la
visita del presidente también la
coordinadora arauco mayeco un grupo
mapuche que defiende la lucha armada
había difundida a través de redes
sociales un comunicado en el que
criticaba la forma en que Boris llegaba
a la región y lo hacía custodiado por
fuerzas especiales lo que dicen defiende
su postura de la militarización del
Walmart puedes decir de los territorios
ancestrales Y es que es la onceava vez
que sea renovado ya el estado de
excepción en la zona que supone la
custodia por parte de los militares de
de las carreteras en un acto que fue
criticado por el presidente borich
cuando era oposición y que fue una de
las primeras medidas que también tomó él
como presidente en uno de sus viajes más
criticados también la oposición ha
criticado que llegara custodiado por
fuerzas especiales son más de 100 los
policías en un amplio dispositivo de
seguridad que custodiaban ivorich y le
recomendaban que no llegue a la región
en bicicleta como ha estado haciendo en
la moneda en imágenes que se han hecho
virales en los últimos días sino que lo
haga en auto que recorra la región en
auto y no rodeado de fuerzas especiales
sin embargo también hay que señalar que
la oposición también crítico a la que
fue su primera ministra del interior
izquierda por visitar la zona con poca
seguridad en ese momento Patricia ahora
cuéntenos porque es importante y cuál es
el contexto que rodea a esta primera
visita
había sido una visita muy solicitada por
diversos sectores políticos también por
las diputados de esa región y había
mucha expectativa por parte
especialmente de las víctimas de la
violencia por personas que han tenido a
familiares a padres a hijos asesinados
por motivo de la violencia que se vive
en esa zona que sufrir Una escalada de
la violencia muy importante en los
últimos meses y en los últimos años
Aunque el conflicto Data de décadas
incluso podríamos decir que de siglos
Pero ha sido especialmente fuerte en los
últimos meses y estas víctimas pedían
justicia se va a reparar se va a
estudiar y revisar el programa de
reparación de las víctimas la agenda del
presidente ha estado muy cargada se ha
tratado de reunir con todos los actores
sociales en se ha trasladado en
helicóptero para poder alcanzar a llegar
a todos es una zona también marcada por
la pobreza es la región más pobre de
chile lo que se refleja en sus
carreteras en sus infraestructura
también en el agua potable en Muchas de
sus escuelas donde los factores como la
pobreza y también factores Como por
ejemplo el robo de la madera o la
posesión de armas y también la seguridad
agroalimentaria son algunas de las
cuestiones que están encima de la mesa
además junto con el conflicto de
restitución de las tierras ancestrales